sobald ich diese feuerkugel rhein
geworfen haben
löw meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen hier zu einer weiteren folge
der minecraft command ich weiß gar nicht
genau welcher tag heute ist ich meine
heute ist freitag weil ich ja immer noch
ein paar produzieren wenn gegen new york
und dem ganzen steht aber ich habe sogar
heute für euch 2,1 parat ich gesagt dass
ich in den nächsten folgen immer noch
einen vorstelle damit da ich derzeit
extrem viele umfangreiche finde und mit
vorproduzieren ich nicht mehr so viel
zeit habe aber ich habe heute trotzdem
zwei dabei die beide auch ein bisschen
mehr was zeigen aber ich hoffe euch
gefällt so wir fangen direkt damit dem
ersten format
wir geben natürlich erstmal ein / gfp
command unterstrich blog so dass wir das
essenziell notwendigste für diese serie
bekommen nämlich einen command blog
nehmen uns einen hebel und fügen diesen
command ein der von super trouper hans
ist den hat er mir zugesagt per mail
nachdem er das video gesehen hatte wo
ich dieses hotel von ihm vorgestellt
hatte hat er gesagt dass er auch einen
maya tempel machen kann und zwar dough
ich jetzt einfach mal drauf und wir
sehen schon wieder eine sehr großen
maschine und wir sehen schon im chat
maya bei super trouper hans hier vorne
baut sich alles rein da sehen wir schon
da kommen nach und nach command blöcke
rein ich meine sogar die maschine müsst
jetzt im moment fällig sein genau und
jetzt stehen mit nämlich im chat let's
go und wir haben im inventar einen
create meyer tempels von was eigentlich
ein
schaaf ich keine ahnung und jetzt können
wir mit diesem spot irgendwohin gehen
lasst uns mal sagen wir geben hier hin
drücken das einfach hier drauf wir sehen
schon da kommt so ein rüstungs ständer
und jetzt baut sich hier einfach ein
maya tempel auf das heißt geht hoch bis
zum sonst was jetzt den mini oben damit
einfach sein wolle block um aber das ist
nicht alles denn an die seiten kommen
noch treppen dann wird auch noch mehr
errichtet und zwar kommen hier jetzt
noch treppen von der seite und hier
kommen auch noch die treppe neben stein
hoch jetzt sehen wir errichtet sich hier
oben so eine kleine ablage mit ein paar
fackeln hier außen rum sind auch lichter
und wir sehen schon im chat maja finish
wenn wir dann hier beispielsweise mal
reingehen sehen man kann ja auch ein
gehen also natürlich mich jetzt mit je
weiter runter gerade bin ich relativ
schnell wieder auf dem level wo ich das
ganze ding gemacht habe also wenn ich
hier beispielsweise reingeht bin ich
quasi nur zwei blöcke beim grund und er
sieht aber recht cool das ist es
wirklich so maya tempel relativ groß und
geht auch diesmal schneller als das
hotel und hat nicht komische bugs und
das kann ich dann beliebig oft anwenden
das heißt ich könnte zum beispielsweise
noch mal den commander eingeben da
könnte ich dann noch einmal tempel
machen sieht ganz cool aus wer eventuell
auch meine idee für die wüsten dass man
da richtige pyramiden macht zwar in
anderen farben dann und mit sandstein
und so aber das ist auf jeden fall
command nummer eins ist man damit ein
maya tempel erschaffen kann so freunde
ihr seht schon wenn ich ins inventar
gehe ich habe einen diamant schwert mit
stärke 5 und ich habe hier alles
mögliche mit schutz hier drauf
verzaubert und zwar wenn ich jetzt mal
einfach den command block hin setzte ein
hebel daneben und dem command einfüge
sage ich euch mal schon mal dass der von
barrett engineers und zwar ist ist der
browser battle commander das heißt ich
muss rechnen altar bauen und dann wird
browser erschaffen und der ist sehr sehr
stark deswegen habe ich mir schon die
rüstung geholt und diese maschine ist
jetzt kreiert und wenn ich jetzt mal
right click bis zu 1 5 clique sehen wir
schon crafter you have to make you have
die make you have to make an alter oder
remake in altersrente videoplayers enamo
standort and drop feiert
internet-start-ups armen browser
das heißt wir müssen wieder so ein
bisschen selber tätig werden und erst
mal ein alter aber und ich zeige euch
jetzt mal wie man den bauten zwar setzt
man hier ein netter stein
ein netter recken hier dauert da und da
und dann gehe ich jetzt hier einfach mal
rum und macht ihr quasi sondern ein
kreis von bisschen und muss danach ihr
lover ein film
das heißt nicht jetzt mal hier eben
schon creative mod für hier überall
wunderschön lava rein und mache jetzt
mal hier außen rum so einen kleinen
fluss damit wir sehen schon hier
drumherum fängt an zu brennen aber das
erstmal egal
dann drücke ich hier diese sachen weg
und setzt sich hier einen cole 30
um diesen kunden rom kommen jetzt jeder
ziegel das heißt ich baue hier die
netter ziegltrum dann errichte ich hier
hier hier und hier noch ein netter
ziegel und somit ist der altar
eigentlich schon erstmal fertig das
einzige was ich jetzt noch machen muss
es einen rüstung ständer hier rein
platzieren dann sehen wir schon wow what
happiness wird direkt dunkel und alles
möglich und auch wenn ich jetzt 10 mal
rein theoretisch einen gäbe passiert
mich gar nichts das ist mir gerade ein
bisschen zu lauter in der umgebung durch
hat man die geräusche gerade auf drei
prozent minimiert und jetzt muss ich
nämlich hier eine netter star einwerfen
und eine feuerkugel und sobald ich diese
feuerkugel rhein geworfen habe
da kommt was passiert er richtet dann
hier auch seine flagge wo man denke ich
relativ kurzen kann dass ein browser ist
und der steht jetzt da oben und wenn ich
jetzt mal rein theoretisch in den game
zu null geht seht ihr schon im chat
princess peach bobby mein mahagoni kill
dem ort browser junior und jetzt kommen
so kleine pause junior an die jetzt alle
auf mich los laufen und gott ich hätte
vielleicht ein gold apfel mir noch
mitnehmen sollen und der lässt auch tmt
explodieren und schmeißt feuerkugeln auf
mich und alles möglich und das ist
gerade acht das ist gerade eigentlich
natürlich weil die alle durch das wasser
ja die kommen trotzdem ich muss jetzt
auf jeden fall erstmal diese ganzen
browser junior hier töten damit ich
überhaupt den browser gleich angreifen
kann bzw sie ihn wiedersehe weil er dann
irgendwie kurzzeitig verschwindet das
heißt ich boxe die ganze druck drauf rum
zum glück hab ich irgendwie ein schutz
diamant sicherung dann habe ich noch
einen stärke 5 schwert habe ich mir
geholt und so weiter und so fort und
jeden moment haben wir auch schon
eigentlich alle browser junior getötet
und jetzt sehen wir wo ist denn der
pause eigentlich hin ihr seht jetzt auch
im chat immer so browser julia sagt ein
vater will kill you von crafter und so
weiter und so fort
aber das problem ist gerade einfach ich
finde den
vater dem browser finde ich gerade gar
nicht ich weiß nicht wer sich darum
tummelt und jetzt muss ich diese ganzen
kleinen hier wieder angreifen und so
weiter und so fort aber den großen
browser den den finde ich gar nicht ich
weiß gar nicht warum also diese kleinen
sind schon relativ stark ist kommt dann
halt jetzt noch nicht so vor weil ich
diese komplett trasse rüstung laden habe
weil er das ist besser als wahre
training
das ist echt grad ich fühle mich gerade
so ein bisschen wie das ist über alles
irgendwie hat's gesehen da hat mich der
pause gerade mütter mit [ __ ] my life
akmal holy mother fucking live das ist
doch da seht ihr jetzt was das ganze
nämlich noch ich bin tot das war toll
ich fliege jetzt wieder da hinten hin wo
ich das ganze zeugs sport hatte da seht
ihr schon auf den altar und so weiter
und so fort also da haben wir gerade
gesehen dass hier der bau sei schon noch
ankam und mit seinen komischen
feuerkugeln auf mich geschossen hat
allerdings würde ich euch gerne mal den
richtigen browser zeigen ich weiß dass
ich den in diesem video wahrscheinlich
dich besiegen kann ich weiß auch gar
nicht ob er noch großartig sachen von
meinen staffel i can't spitfire kennste
kill you soll das heißt nämlich dass
sagte er wenn er quasi keine fireballs
verschießen kann nicht mehr diese feier
charge teile sondern wenn er quasi nur
noch diese tnt sachen setzen kann und an
mal der solar kann ich trotzdem noch
töten eventuell ist es gab ein bisschen
feige aber ich liebe kämpft die gal
allem prey treffen heute ist ein
bisschen lächerlich aber naja ihr habt
schon gesehen jetzt grade wieder tnt in
die luft geflogen hier oben sind über
diese feier teil aber ich würde gern da
sitzt die dollar materien überall in die
luft aber ich würde gerne einfach mal
sehen wo der da ist er da ist der
browser und dem muss jetzt angreifen und
da guck jetzt habe ich ihn einmal
geschlagen jetzt ist er wieder dies bei
uns ein bisschen und ich muss jetzt mal
seine ganzen browser junior töten damit
er sieht wie tief muss ich irgendwann
mal eingreifen so nett war okay ich säge
hat das dann links auf der seite noch
ein kleiner bowser junior ist
beziehungsweise hier unten den werde ich
jetzt versuchen ihn zu töten und dann
mal schauen ob er mich dann realisiert
der pause das ist einfach nur soja komm
bitte boss realisiere mich so in etwa
aber irgendwie hier kommt irgendwie gar
keiner mehr also ich weiß nicht das
einzige was ich eigentlich auch noch
zeigen wollte war dass wenn man den töte
bekommt man ganz viel erfahrung und da
steht dann so auf faktors mich getötet
so in etwa und dann bekommt man von dem
bau sonne rüstung das heißt diese
rüstung ist quasi so
grün gelb orange tv browser halt ist und
mit dieser rüstung kann man wenn ich
damit beispielsweise über diese steine
hier laufe wird das zum net direkt also
so wie hier wenn ich damit über erde
laufe wie das auch zum netter reck wenn
ich damit über sand laufen wird das zum
netter ziegeln wenn ich damit über
wasser laufen geht das zur obsidian und
lava damit kann man quasi das terrain um
einen herum verändern was schon mal sehr
sehr cool ist das ganze kann ich euch
gerade aber nicht mehr zeigen weil der
bau sei irgendwie verschwunden ist ich
weiß nicht wo er hin ist ich finde auch
keine pause junior mehr er schreibt ja
auch nichts mehr im chat das letzte war
mein vater bull kill you aber irgendwie
hat er ja auch geschafft aber dann
vielleicht mag sein dass ich kurzzeitig
gestorben bin oder so aber keine ahnung
jedenfalls war das jetzt kommt nummer
zwei und ich würde euch das echte ja
noch zeigen aber irgendwie funktioniert
zahl gerade hier freunde das war's mit
der commands folge für heute wenn ihr
das video sehe bin ich gerade in new
york falls ihr euch wird gerade glaube
ich von der seite attackiert wenn ihr
das video rade lebt bin ich in new york
das heißt wenn ihr das coole sachen aus
new york sehen wollt könnt ihr mir bei
snapshot folglich laser luca und wenn es
euch gefallen habe ich mich über eine
bewertung freuen und wir sehen uns dann
im nächsten video wieder